فيها تاي من تكرار وقوع الزلازل وعدد
الضحايا يرتفع بوتين يعلن تعليق اهم
معاهده نوويه بين روسيا وامريكا النيابه
تكشف تفاصيل وفاه ملاكم مصري بالضربه
القاضيه هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من تركيا حيث ارتفع عدد الضحايا
نتيجه الزلزالين اللذين ضربا مسائل اثنين
مقاطعتها هاتاي الى سته قتله و294 جريحا
بينهم 18 شخصا في حاله حرجه اداره الطوارئ
التركيه اوضحت ان قوه زلزلين بلغت
6.45 درجات على مقياس مشيره الى ان 90 هزه
ارتداديه اعقبت الزلزلين كما انهارت مباني
في عده مدن فيما افاد مراسل العربيه بان
معظم السكان غادروا هاتاي وسط مخاوف شديده
من تكرار الزلزال وسط تقارير تتحدث عن
وجود اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض بعد وقوع
الزلزلين الجديدن
[موسيقى]
وبعد دقائق قليله من وقوع الزلزلين غرد
العالم الهولندي المثير للجدل فرانك
هوجربات بتغريده يلفت فيها الى يلفت فيها
نظره متابعيه لتوقعه حدوث زلازل جديده في
المنطقه قبل وقوعها بنحو 24 ساعه تقريبا
فرانك عاد نشره تغريده كتب فيها قد يحدث
نشاط زلزالي اقوى في الفتره من 20 الى 22
فبراير تقريبا ومن المحتمل ان يبلغ ذروته
يوم 22 وعلق فرانك قائلا على هذه التغريده
هذه تغريده الامس في حال لم تروها وكان
العالم
توقع حدوث زلزاله تركيا العنيف قبل ثلاثه
ايام من وقوعه فجر السادس من فبراير
في خطاب وجهه الى الامه اعلن رئيسه الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين تعليق مشاركه بلاده في
معاهده نيو ستارت لضبط الاسلحه النوويه
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بوتن شدد في تصريحاته على ان انه في حال
اجراء الولايات المتحده اختبارا للاسلحه
النوويه فان موسكو سترد بالمثل
بوتين قال ان موسكو تعلم على وجه اليقين
ان بعض الشخصيات في واشنطن تفكر بالفعل في
امكانيه اجراء تجارب طبيعيه لاسلحتها
النوويه واضاف ان روسيا لن تكون اول ما
يفعل ذلك ولكن اذا اجرت الولايات المتحده
مثل هذه الاختبارات سنقوم ايضا بذلك على
حد قوله
هذا وجدد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
انتقاداته لرئيس الحليب جو بايدن وللسياسه
التي انتهجها في الملف الروسي الاوكراني
معتبرا ان التصرفات بايدن وسياسته تجاه
اوكرانيا تدفع الانسانيه نحو حرب عالميه
ثالثه وفي منشور على حسابه في شبكه تروس
سوشل كتب ترامب اذا تابعتم وفاهمتم
الخطوات التي يتخذها بايدن فيما يتعلق
باوكرانيا فسترون انه يقوم بشكل ممنهج
وربما دون وعي بدفعنا نحو ما قد يصبح
قريبا حربا عالميه ثالثه متسائلا بالقول
اليس هذا جنونا فيما ياتي تعليق ترامب هذا
بعد زياره مفاجئه قام بها بايدن الى كييف
الاثنين
وفي خبرنا الاخير كشفت النيابه المصريه
نتائج التحقيقات في واقعه وفاه الملاكم
رامز حسام في نهائي بطوله الجمهوريه
للملاكمه وسائل اعلام محليه افادت بان
تقرير النيابه العامه اكد تعرض حسام
لاصابه قويه في المباراه النهائيه من هذه
البطوله مشيره الى ان تقرير الطب الشرعي
اوضح ان الملاكم الملاكم توفي متاثرا
باصابه بالراس احدثت نزيفا بالمخ ادى
لتوقف المراكز الحيويه عن العمل فيما جاء
هذا التقرير مخالفا لما اكده الاتحاد
المصري للملاكمه الذي ذكر ان حسام توفي
نتيجه تراكمات قديمه تعود الى سنوات سابقه
وليس بفعل اصابه جديده